the tour finals dude that magnus was
playing here in the studio i think
magnus
had some
crushing results against him then so if
he can find back to that form um it
could be
a good finish to today for for magnus
all right ding ding ding it's what we
hear david the game has started and what
are we seeing we're seeing the sicilian
defense one of the most popular openings
in chess but also from black one of the
most counter-attacking openings in chess
and magnus hasn't handled it in the
traditional way he's putting his own
personal stamp on this opening white
queen coming out very early we normally
recommend not to do this definitely
don't try this at home especially if
you're first starting out the game white
queen now attacked by the black knight
is going to have to retreat queens are
the most valuable pieces so you need to
save them for later any time the queen
is attacked she has to retreat because
she's always going to get hit by lower
valued pieces so magnus losing some time
with his queen there but he's opened up
the center and
he is now also ready as white to castle
the king off to the queen side to the
left side of the board that is quite
rare in chess in general but in the open
sicilian it's one of the most fighting
ways to handle the position and i think
magnus is going to do that over the next
two or three turns white's king is going
to go off to that left side black's
king's probably going to park itself on
the opposite flank and then we're going
to see both sides race to try and attack
the enemy monarch and uh yeah right now
rare position ivanka it is rare position
um i'm just looking at who's played this
with the white pieces and i can only see
one grand master predk
apart from that it's just been
international masters and strong very
strong amateur players so not the most
popular opening choice so maybe
magnus is resorting to his old strategy
of just kind of catching his opponent
unawares and in some sideline
yeah and it shows he's over that quick
draw he had earlier um against ding with
black maybe he wasn't in a fighting mood
but now he definitely is because this
opening with white is really really
dynamic uh already there's an imbalanced
pawn structure especially if as
mentioned both kings castle and opposite
flanks that in chess that's one of the
most
kind of double-edged things so right now
white just pushes upon it solidifies the
white pawn stronghold in the center and
uh yeah we'll see black start to develop
pieces now as well
starting with this dark squad bishop on
a great diagonal we should mention this
black bishop
it's a defensive piece but also
potentially an attacking piece to
early days but i'm excited i think this
is going to be a fun game to watch later
okay cool i was a little bit surprised
actually by black developing that dark
square bishop it looks like the most
natural move on the board after all
black wants to get his king to safety
but is it going to be so safe because
you know
david highlighted the white king is
planning to go on the opposite side to
the left side and when that happens when
the kings are on different sides of the
ball it's war and you're going to see
trades of the dark squared bishops
you're going to see porn storms you're
going to see everything so i thought
maybe it was kind of sophisticated way
of playing to delay that dark square
bishop and instead concentrating on
developing the other pieces yeah i guess
ivanka as black here you would be afraid
of quite a thematic idea um one we see
time and time again in this type of
position the bishop coming and trading
off uh black's pride and joy and okay
magnus not committing his king yet but
this type of idea is typical we see a
trade here you'd never ever want to
capture white's bishop because this
would allow the white queen
in the vicinity of your king and uh now
there will be checkmating ideas all over
the place this black king lacking
defenders only one real defender this
night and that's not going to be enough
on the dark squares
so magnus is going to keep that one up
his sleeve for later instead of going
for this bishop trade first he is
actually if we catch up with the game
position just improved his knight so
just brought his knight towards the
center he's waiting for black to put his
king on this side and then he's going to
go on the attack and the attack includes
moves as the one we mentioned getting
rid of this defender but also uh if
ginger gm was here in the studio with us
simon williams he would no doubt uh
throw this pawn up the board in order to
activate the white rook actually on this
line towards the black king later on
push this pawn forward and try to
initiate some trades to open up this key
attacker
and ginger gm will be with us in the
studio tomorrow
so
looking forward to that
yeah so right now it's tension neither
side really wants to commit the king
because once you show your opponent like
there we go just a bishop move instead
once you show your opponent where you're
going to put the king that is the signal
for them to attack so often you delay it
and delay it and delay it as long as
possible because then your opponent
can't commit the attack yet if white
went on the attack on one side then the
black king maybe would run to the other
side of the board so that's why they're
playing with pieces and they're actually
disobeying the classical rules here of
castling your king as early as possible
normally you want to get your king to
safety on one of the flanks but here
they're just uh hoping that they're safe
enough in the middle for now the two
kings and uh well magnus has now posed a
very pressing question to duda he's
attacked the knight sorry he's attacked
the bishop with his knight and he's
saying hey do you want to make a trade
and
instinctively i'm like no because i like
my bishops but this is the type of
position where every move that you make
matters
so
would you just come out with the queen
to the side of the board leave the
bishop there or would you kind of go oh
sound the retreat yeah very good
question ivanka i guess once you've said
a you normally say b and okay he does
commit his king if black's bishop did
run away from a potential trade then
you've moved your bishop twice in the
opening you don't normally want to move
the same piece twice
so you're right white definitely will be
tempted now to use the knight and
capture black's light squared bishop uh
but knights and bishops worth roughly
the same it's not clear that that
necessarily benefits white yet uh i
think black just needed to save as much
time as possible and now he's ready to
castle with the king because white
doesn't have this idea that we
highlighted of white's dark square
bishop coming and trading off the bishop
next to the black king
so duda kind of waited to an opportune
moment and he has committed the king the
computer evaluation though shot up in
white's favor so
maybe thinking that white's potential
attack against the black king is going
to be quicker than any potential attack
that black can organize against white's
king and there we go simon williams
would be proud watching uh i think from
his hotel room in oslo
throwing pawns now towards the
opponent's king this is what we want to
see no quick draws just both sides
attacking each other and uh black yet to
organize an attack but white is ready if
that pawn pushes one square further
forward white's rook in the corner is
ready or ready to join the attack and
actually maybe even decide the game
quite quickly harry the h1 and that is
one of those
fashion moves basically in chess super
popular with every top player now yeah
in certain openings it's they this type
of pawn push has always been popular but
now computers modern computers
especially ai like alpha zero they have
showed that pushing the
pushing the pawns in front of your rooks
uh actually that can be even more
effective than humans previously thought
so uh yeah in all types of positions all
types of random positions that pawn is
whizzing up the board and causing
trouble now
and uh okay meanwhile duda centralizes
his night
yeah i have to say our friend simon
williams was a real pioneer in that
field yeah
he was doing it long before anyone
anyone thought it was any good and
in fact everyone thought that he was a
bit nuts
they were just like you know simon plays
this rick moo porn move anywhere anytime
any against anything
and uh okay we do have some moves
because that age pawn harry has found
itself on the fifth row i mean that is
so whoa look that is scary each one yeah
and it's now gone and now you can see as
david highlighted that rook in the
corner that now has a nice open line and
uh all white needs to do now is start
attacking along the dark squares yeah
and there's a real dilemma right now for
duda as well do you capture with this
pawn but now this rook is on a
completely he has done this it's on a
completely open line towards the black
king now all you need to do is really
eliminate this defender and then there's
going to be checkmating ideas all over
the place the other option was actually
tempting as well but less appealing
because now there's an open diagonal
towards the black king in this way
so either either capture there had pros
and cons duda though really playing with
fire at this early stage and look at the
evaluation bar it really likes white's
position i would be very very tempted at
some point to just move this knight out
the way either this way or even retreat
it one square and then if you can just
bring your bishop eliminate this guy
it's going to be checkmate for example
if black takes a timeout bishop moves
forward and no matter what black does
now it's just checkmate the white queen
jumps in and the queen and rook together
are the most fearsome duo even stronger
than queen and knight sometimes and this
is already checkmate and wow this is
with natural moves we could see a
checkmate in under 20 moves unless okay
he's actually gone for this magnus
carlsen um yeah unless dude is really
coming up with some genius defense i
think we're gonna see magnus just crush
this game this is already a deadly idea
if this bishop drops if this bishop gets
exchanged then black's king is doomed
how impressed are you with the world
champion right now
well it is impressive but at the same
time
i'm a little bit shocked by doodah's
play because this is very thematic
um everything that david's highlighted
is uh the dream of every english chess
player you know we we we
we love this kind of frame of attack you
know push the age pawn up the board
trade of the dark squares check mate
along the h line i mean
we've kind of made it into a formula and
i'm just a bit shocked that
duda hasn't kind of he's taken big risks
and hasn't quite taken care of his king
he's allowed magnus to get everything he
wanted and it's still such an early
stage in the game um yeah ivanka you
made me chuckle there because you're
right in uh in kind of world chess in
general they regard the english as
having no culture no sophistication
really we see our opponent's king we
just go for the opportunity
it's like caveman chess uh in russia you
know they just like to control
everything take their long-term
strategic advantages in england we just
want to go
for checkmate but sometimes it's
effective and
simon williams has perfected that art
and magnus now yeah i mean he's making
it look simple um just it's it's just
step by step open a line for your rook
get rid of your opponent's best defender
and then check me and uh
dude knows i mean you can see in his
body language he knows he's already
struggling and the more i look at it the
more i think he's going to have to take
some drastic measures maybe even some
crazy sacrifices just to survive another
few more moves but it's not going to be
easy yeah so already back to the wall
defensive job for duda it kind of
reminded me of you know your comment
really reminded me of two
chest variations that we've named so one
of them is like called the 150 attack
and in the under the english grading
system i think 150 is round about i
would say 1700 right
seven so
a strong player but not not contending
at the highest levels and the 150
attackers based basically is named like
that because it says even a 1700 player
can play this attack very efficiently
and then we have another one which is
kind of along the modes of this which is
called the barry and you're like well
why is it called the barry and it's like
any you know we have this expression and
any tom dick and harry well it's like
any tom dick and barry could play this
so um yeah the brits and the puns yes
yeah this uh actually that's one of the
things i fell in love with when i first
started chess every opening name has a
quirky reason behind it i mean the
hippopotamus defense the orangutan
opening like there's plenty of uh
openings and there's always a sneaky
reason some are named after great
players of course some are named after
places but um yeah those ones you
mentioned javanco and actually those
ones have very similar ideas to this
opening um so it's always the same idea
you put your bishop on one square you
line it up with the queen you open up
the rook and checkmate and uh yeah maybe
dude just not familiar well
of course he's familiar with these ideas
but maybe just not familiar with the
defensive ideas that he could have
employed i think his big mistake was
committing the black king
he should have kept magnus guessing for
a few more moves once he put the king on
this side of the board that was like a
red flag to a bull magnus immediately
going for the king and
this is just a deadly threat white's
bishop going and trading itself off for
the black dark square bishop this is one
to remember for everyone at home wow so
um is there any way for duda to defend
i mean it looks
it's
don't i don't see a natural way to be
honest with you
maybe the knight can come and try to
block blockade to block the rook's line
on the
corner yep so the black knight could
maybe plug this file temporarily but
it's definitely a short-term measure i
mean once white castles the king at some
point soon the pawn will come up and
dislodge this knight and then it's back
where you came from the black knight has
to retreat and then the same ideas again
i just have a feeling that at some point
in the next few moves for example if the
rook comes across uh the bishop comes up
black is just going to have to step back
with his bishop this bishop is just
worth too much and even if it comes at
the cost of material
at least after bishop takes right now
queen takes the queen comes to the
defense and stops white from entering on
this square because the queen covers it
so i think black's gonna have to give up
something in order to just survive and
uh we should also mention what magnus
has just done he's put his knight on
this square meaning that any trade for
example knight takes will just be met by
a capture and black loses even more time
and every move matters now black can't
afford to lose time just making trades
because it's all about the king and this
idea is still in the air
that is the the sort of the name for the
milwaukee championship this year every
move matters yeah every move does matter
yeah and i think if dude doesn't find an
accurate defense or
i mean if he doesn't find something
really
really sneaky to trick magnus magnus's
moves are just so easy to find and
logical and
we could be looking at what we call a
miniature in chess that's a win under 20
moves you nearly never really nearly
never see that at top level
um
yeah so
i'm liking that tweet as well me
blunders and magnus
are funny viewers yeah they're great and
keep those tweets coming and remember
you just use the hashtag chesschamps
so yeah
yeah poor duder head in hands he's been
on such a hot streak actually the last
couple of games but
suddenly his chances might be
disappearing because it was yes um
yesterday the last game was his first
victory in the tournament so maybe he
was riding high and thinking yes i've
turned my luck around and then okay he
meets uh magnus magnus tricks him like
this and now
he's uh whoa he's struggling
and there's no decent weight because
even the lines where where david showed
where black tries to sacrifice
i say sacrifice just give away some
material just to stay alive
it didn't look great yeah it didn't look
great because none of black's pieces
were in great squares
yeah meanwhile magnus there he knows
he's done the hard work but
maybe feeling the effects of kovitz
still um just covering his head maybe
just trying to work out some variations
calculate that's often the body
languages you have chess players they're
often looking at the ceiling as in the
queen's gambit show or they're looking
off to the side or heading hands
um i often pretend i'm i mean sometimes
i'm genuinely having a nap at the board
but normally i just close my eyes when
i'm trying to calculate and
have you fallen asleep by the board
david too many times really yes i think
i oh i shouldn't say this on uh but i
was playing for england lately and i
fell asleep for around 20 minutes so uh
that was
um in over the more classical chess of
course nobody's watching
yeah luckily i woke up and i still had
enough time on my clock to i i made a
draw against arteriev in that game so it
didn't cost me anything too much but
i wanted to be fresh and maybe the air
wasn't great in that right exactly
so if i mean in a classroom i can
remember this falling asleep in a
classroom what is the problem in a
classroom when or in a room when people
start falling asleep is it too warm is
it some particles
what's the co2 it is okay so that's very
common in in office environments and you
know people sitting down to take
decisions and they discuss for hours and
hours and hours and then they think
they're going to make be able to make a
decision by the end of the meeting when
they built up all the co2 in the meeting
room
and nobody's thinking straight and
that's usually when you think like same
with when you're driving a car you think
like you're tired maybe you need a
coffee or or
it's usually the co2 so usually what you
need is just fresh air just open the
window open the window if you're driving
in in the meeting room open the door
things like that simple tricks
so the racing co2 is is very
the common reason for the drowsiness
you're feeling so but in businesses then
if you like you say they're in a meeting
for a couple of hours and then they're
gonna take that huge decision decision
should be taken
in the start of the meeting
ah or if you at least
say okay half an hour break everyone go
to the park and we meet in half an hour
and then we decide or take the meeting
outside in the park
even better better ah
wow whoa and where did magnus go and
what happens to the bar yeah um dude
just retreating his bishop actually the
bishop came from this square a few moves
ago so that doesn't help black's
position at all um white does have a
winning advantage now but magnus is he
disconnected yeah that's yeah if he is
is he gonna get back into time
smiling magnus coming back and i guess
he has a reason to smile the bar is
loving the situation but has he logged
off is he disconnected and remind us
what are the rules if we do have
disconnection for one player so i think
if the player reconnects within 30
seconds they just get given their time
back and the game goes on
it might be even longer than that they
get given their time back but if they
are disconnected for the rest of their
remaining time on the clock so if magnus
doesn't get back in the next 12 or so
minutes then i think
um he would be defaulted the game so
um yeah let's hope he gets back we want
to see how this game proceeds i don't
think doodle would want to win by kind
of default either so and it could also
of course be that he is connected but
his camera just logged off
so they are saying he is logged in
and is duda still connected or is he
just very still yeah that's true did he
freeze as well no no no he's still there
i saw him shaking
so he's just in full concentration mode
he needs he knows he needs to use
absolutely everything to survive
and
going back to your your
your when you were talking about co2
levels is this the reason why everyone
falls asleep on the plane
oh
because i i mean i once i always fall
asleep right i mean i once came back
from a flight from gibraltar to london
and i went to the bathroom and after i
came back i noticed every single person
was asleep and i thought there must be
something in there some speculations
around that yeah oh oh okay we're in
conspiracy land okay
there's a lot of conspiracy theories
obviously when it comes to uh you know
wanting the passengers just to sleep
throughout the entire trip but
i don't think that's the case but
recirculating there might be one of the
reasons they have like really good hepa
filters uh filters to remove like
um uh particles and and potential you
know harmful things in the air but the
co2 isn't something you just can't
you know remove from the air then you
would need to have fresh air in
and and to be honest i don't know about
the aerodynamics on bringing fresh air
in in airplanes but
who knows
and in my defense by the way this
falling asleep story there were 500
people in one room and i think the co2
levels must have been super high i i
heard about that actually that the air
was very very dry and uh
yeah yeah so i've got my excuses ready
yeah but it's right i mean chess it's i
mean there is a reason everything is and
the meltwater championship are working
together it's the perfect fit right
chess and air quality it's just so
important and these huge tournaments and
chess olympiads and stuff like that we
have so many players in the same room
and playing classical over the world
chess for hours and hours yeah both
online and over the broadcasts i mean
online it's important in the home office
of course to have perfect conditions i
mean every little detail matters but
also yeah these massive tournaments as i
mentioned 500 players there's no windows
in this uh tournament that i mentioned
for example and
tournament organizers really got to take
this into consideration there have been
health problems among some players
suffering i mean if you're playing two
weeks in a room like that for six seven
hours at a time every day it's uh it can
get difficult so
um yeah i mean
the older i've got the more i'm aware of
these things but air quality is
definitely one of the big factors for
chess players and obviously in sports
and in in the top level of sports we
know margins is everything right so
to actually practice and play in the
best possible air quality i guess could
actually be the difference between
success and failure absolutely and why
take the chance
and uh magnus is back yes
that connected but he's been thinking
for almost five minutes on this movie
this is one of those critical moments in
the game
um i think magnus's best move is also
the most obvious move so um yeah i'm not
sure whether he was properly
disconnected the whole time or whether
he'll get his time back but either way
magnus once he refocuses
will for sure try and go towards that
black king and um just to show what we
expect to happen right now black's
bishop has just retreated the idea
behind that move is to actually free up
this square for the black knight the
knight trying to jump in to attack the
white queen attack the white dark square
bishop but this is very logical as we
mentioned several times already the
bishop does jump in magnus has played
this this is the key defender black's
dart squad bishop and once you remove
that there's going to be checkmating
ideas all over the place and
actually duda now resorting to the plan
ivanka mentioned bringing the knight to
the side but actually i think there's a
few ways to win this game on the spot
you can even just for example trade the
bishops off if the black knight retreats
and takes then the white queen jumps in
with this checkmating idea we mentioned
if the black king recaptures instead
then white can even sacrifice right now
rook takes knight getting rid of that
key defender and whites for example
after a night trade can just jump in
with the queen this is a check
this black king is not going to survive
it's going to move to the side
black can uh
just play his next few moves on
autopilot because white's queen is just
going to do all the damage and now all
white needs to do for example move the
bishop out the way move the king out the
way next move and then swing the
remaining rook into the game this black
king has no defenders around it it's
going to end in checkmate
at some point so this one i'm not sure
magnus even needs to risk any potential
sacrifices but right now if he just
wants to take a timeout he could even
just take this knight for example
he can also just castle his king but i
would keep things simple and he does do
that taking this bishop
and
yeah i'm expecting to see some clever
moves by magnus but he will surely
finish this one off yeah and a lot of
enjoyment for everyone because we do
enjoy
a well
very convincing attack so now we're
waiting to see whether rook takes night
and it's on the board
it made sense you know just blast open
the king because
um opening lines is like the currency
for attack the more lines that you open
against the king the more vulnerable and
exposed he is so now we're expecting
knight takes night just as you said
that's uh at first i was about to
suggest the white queen jumping in with
the check first but that would have
allowed black's knight to come back and
block so now this move i mean this
series of moves that i mentioned is
actually happening on the board the
other reason magnus can go for this is
because black's king can never escape
the king has to move now and at the very
very minimum there's a safety net for
magnus he could just give checks forever
with his queen and black's king cannot
escape so that would end in a repetition
and a draw so it's always nice in chess
to have a safety net so even if you
calculate wrong even if you take a risk
and it kind of backfires to be able to
make a draw at the very least is uh a
nice
a nice thing just to have in your pocket
and now black's king steps back in this
way and
there we go the bishop moves the white
king is about to evacuate the first rank
or maybe even just castle and then that
white rook in the left-hand corner it's
not doing anything but it is going to be
the piece that delivers the killer blow
um what black's king is just completely
helpless no defenders around it
yeah what to do black's pieces are still
asleep look at the black queen look at
the black rooks unable to jump to the
defense and there's no connection as
well you know
we've always said actually it's been a
theme in this tournament that uh when
the defending queen is offside cannot
get to her king
then this is when the black king is the
most vulnerable one here and i mean
there's just no connection this bishop
and that is proudly sitting on the e6
square well it gets in the way yeah
actually even if you give black three
moves with the black queen there's no
way to get round to the defense of her
king so yeah that's how uh helpless
dude is feeling right now he's leaning
back and body language in chess we've
talked about it a bit but if a player
leans back either they're very confident
or they know their position is hopeless
yeah well this will certainly make some
of our twitter audience very happy
because magnus of course has a lot of
support and carly roche
says uh chess champs
chess let's go magnus in her selfie
there she is supporting magnus and
lavinia bratis says
chess all the way and this time she has
a chest maestro biscuit
very very tasty we're jealous i never oh
never heard of it
but they sell them here in norway really
yeah oh we have a result
yep young christophe duda has resigned
magnus carlsen is actually shaking his
head but
it is a win for the world champion an
important win for him actually